[Music]
and celebrity cheater news oh you too
else is new
that's true if you were if you were
married to a celebrity and he cheated on
you but he just gave you like millions
and millions a month it's okay okay you
could cheat on me all day kind of what
if he like gives you millions that you
can invest in to your own business and
you can make well I'll put up with it
are you a celebrity too or are you a
nobody you're nobody
oh for sure millions of dollars a month
but if I'm a celebrity - and he's being
mean to me yeah then you don't need that
I like going your snare it's a he still
so I mean like she didn't change she
said cuz if you said she it's like yeah
yeah a hundred percent is too easy yeah
it has to make it difficult yeah that's
a gangsta might get your [ __ ]
gangster hero submitted by iPhone LX IX
oh [ __ ] that's really new world are they
really coming out with the eight and
then yeah yeah actually ten what's the
difference it's a two thousand dollar
phone there's like one dinosaurs on it
or some [ __ ] that's it it's like emojis
remember what I told you to have facial
recognition now yeah and no one will
ever be able to hack into my phone cuz
I'll do my chin fake oh yeah so every
time if they'll be event yeah Kevin Hart
apologize after being caught cheating on
his wife he cheat on this one too
didn't you do that I will say let me say
this real quick alright I'm working on a
project with them so I support whatever
he does best mom man why does he have to
publicly apologize he just has to say
sorry to her and then it's cool the fans
are talking [ __ ] so is this is the whole
situation it's pretty freakin crazy
were you there but you guys know so this
is what it's like so hear me
yeah me and Kate that's what I called my
the way okay you met a one time okay is
assisted or some yeah so me and K right
so we were talking right no I just I
just saw Twitter and like Twitter start
blowing up but and then I you know
French from Sacramento were texting me
they're like so so what's up with your
boy I like my boy who's my boy you know
but but why would you even know to tell
if I would be even assume that you know
what we're not on social media as much
as everybody else so like everybody else
is glued on Twitter glued on Instagram
and so I guess what happened was the the
stripper that he was [ __ ] she wasn't
even that pretty it's never about looks
though
and so like she had her phone leaned up
against the wall on the floor and it was
hitting hit record and while he was
[ __ ] her so she was clearly using
that for extortion to extort money on
and so for him it was his thing to come
out and just like it's gonna shoot he
didn't wanna get extorted so he just
came clean with it and that's very smart
it is you know in his own like PR his
wife just pregnant yes I'm here too it's
crazy because like Twitter's blowing up
and his [ __ ] making me laugh I feel
terrible but I'm laughing because he
calls her rib you know bitter cool right
so now they call her the McRib because
and it sucks because like she's getting
attacked that she's getting made fun of
for his for his action you know so it's
like but she knew he was married she was
doing what she does yeah wait the
strippers getting attacked you the wife
no the wife so he calls my the wife so
what the calling of mcribs but but but I
don't see the insult in that cuz I
personally love it when I see billboards
like the McRib is back I'm like oh [ __ ]
an old friend came back to see me
and people are saying it's like Just
Desserts because she cheated I guess
like his ex his wife ex-wife was cheated
on by her
oh sweet you know exactly what this new
girl that's what people are saying I
don't know you know I feel like though
it's like rare when you're rich and
powerful and you're actually staying
together and
you have a boring marriage like normal
people then I think that's the rare
thing when people expect that [ __ ] from
celebrities and all that I'm just like
why can you name celebrities that are
cel together now yeah I met I've met a
few celebrities but they've all been
relation yeah but they're [ __ ]
everybody you know there's a there's
those random celebrities where you would
think that they cheer and everyone but
they don't like Lil Jon crazy
oh yeah he's not a party out of luck
he's very quiet drinks tea yeah as a
British accent right didn't drink yeah
you've got like a cuz Lil Jon is the one
that started you like crunk juice yeah
exactly buddy drinkin I sat down with
him for like an hour
hello Gina yeah I feel like he was
really eloquent and he was very sick
what is it was like Dave Chappelle
portrays yes I think that's what he's
making fun of actually like he talks
about his wife like I love her I've been
with her since before every see all
auto-tune evident like he's just like
this really nice guy he didn't like want
some kombucha he's also uh he's a he's
an ordained minister whatever you get
married if I got married to handle John
or dating my dad be to be sick Barry
Gina do you want a deal
anyone I know literally anybody could
not like I wanted to really do you take
volleyball to marry you and huh you say
yeah yeah Kevin Hart scandal so what
happened here is that he posted a video
on his Instagram just talking about how
he was a victim of an attempted
extortion where the the person the
extortion is wanted ten million dollars
that's an expensive piece of [ __ ] yeah
how much is he worth no xpp I think I
looked it up
because I was comparing him in the rock
in the rocket took edge him by a couple
hundred five hundred million oh my god
that means Kevin Hart is three hundred
millions I believe the rock is four
hundred million
yeah but they with extortion it keeps
going and going and going that's that's
the thing is like they don't be stuck
with it they go for ten million now and
then they'll go for fifty she's dog knew
she wouldn't she went too high she
should have just said like a mill okay
tell him to tell me this story okay so
this is all happening right and then
this video this four-minute video came
out and then with a lot of text on it
saying Kevin Hart started the Harvey
relief fund because he knew that this is
gonna come out so he wanted to come out
like he was a good guy this is what the
extortionist wrote on the video and then
they're just what's the Harvey Relief
Fund by the way okay he was calling out
all of the other celebrities to pitch
him money are see yes then this
extortion is what will happen when or
what happen nothing is quite yeah people
found out who the woman in the video was
cuz there's video clips of him in the
bedroom you could see someone [ __ ] but
you can't really tell who it is so it's
insinuated that it's Kevin with this
girl and then you also see other clips
I couldn't buy an actual video so it was
just what's being reported that you see
other clips where he was like really
cozy on this woman's like chest area and
she just it looks like you know he does
not his wife so why is he getting butt
titties make nice pillows that's a fact
so then finally the the woman in the
video came out because her lawyer Lisa
bloom who she represents a ton of people
she came out saying that she represents
her and so her name is Monty ax the bog
and she's a 27 year old from Long Beach
and she claims that she has nothing to
do with making the video she's not an
extortionist she's not a stripper as a
lot of people were doing because they're
reporting her as a traveling stripper
because it all happened in the
cosmopolitan in Vegas but she's like
that's not true what is she then she's
actually a musician and a model so she's
like trying to burp yeah I don't know
any stripper that goes yep I'm a
stripper they're always a student or a
model or some other [ __ ] so yes give
kevin has been caught up in a whole
bunch of cheating scandals before so
like David mentioned before he was
married to Tori and they got - they got
married in 2003 they have two kids they
got divorced in 2011 big and Tori claims
I was because of his infidelity and even
Kevin himself and his data says he
admits it - yeah and so apparently when
he was being unfaithful on Tori with and
Nico so his current wife and then Anika
was saying that being together she's
real pretty she's really pretty
well first let me show you Kevin Hart's
Instagram video got that Kevin Hart face
right there hold that's the cheating
face every scene though the photos like
every celebrity is untreated they always
do that
having said that face um I'm at a place
in my life where I feel like I have a
target on my back
and because of that I should make smart
decisions and recently I did you know
I'm not perfect I'm not gonna sit up
here and say that I hammer or claim to
be in any way shape or form and I made a
bad error in judgment and put myself in
an environment where only bad things can
happen and they did and in doing that I
know that I'm gonna hurt the people
closest to me who I've talked to and
apologized to being my wife and my kids
and I just you know it's a shitty moment
it's a shitty moment when you when you
know you're wrong and there's no excuses
for your wrong behavior at the end of
the day man I just simply got to do
better but I'm not gonna also allow a
person to to have financial gain off of
my mistakes and in this particular
situation that's what was attempted I
said I'd rather fess up to my mistakes
yeah so that's the video you posted on
his Instagram I forgot to mention - when
this whole the Vegas thing happened it
was during the same time as his wife's
birthday so that's so he missed the
birthday and he went to Vegas to [ __ ] a
stripper that's what it seems Oh
musician and model so we this is his
great wife I did she tall yeah all right
well she's normal hi Sam she looks great
pregnant that's a pretty fly suit though
no this is a screenshot from that Vegas
video let's see
so she's the so-called extortionist yeah
this girl so the the person that was
extorting is claiming that she isn't
she's extorting yeah so we don't
according to the woman what's her name
Mangia according to maanteeeca
they still don't like they don't know
who it is that durian Kevin but she
claimed it's not her oh the girl isn't
the one extorting that's what she's
claiming well what if she sent it to
your friends you go to jail for
extortion so that's what no one wants to
admit extortion that's why go to jail
for that [ __ ] so I'm gonna show you guys
so here are some screenshots of the
video that I couldn't get I can't see
this one and then they're back here
here's Kevin here she is and then right
here they're backing it up I can't see
okay yeah so then this is a month here
the recording artist and mom yeah but
this photo that was circulating that's
when she was a stripper
this is the photo saying that she was a
traveling stripper oh [ __ ] that's what
they would use where they get that
though I'm not sure but she's blaming
she's not internet knows a lot about her
[ __ ] looks like she's out of no because
recently someone said that I was a
stripper and escort I was like oh [ __ ]
tell me more come on Gina we all know
that you're a hooker yeah we do it
together we know our camera team bosoms
and bosoms come on
tandem the quadrupoles yep show them
stuff
oh [ __ ] those shoulders yeah yeah I'm a
terrible stripper than it needs to be
making more money that's why I'm saying
dude we oughta buy you two I mean I sell
myself short that's true that's just
nothing stealing my customers Monte I
did do a press conference with her with
her lawyer and this is what she said
my name is once yes Tabasco I've been
doing that thing I was involved with
Kevin Hart months ago since then my
pictures she can only read three words
at once lies written about me high five
guys huge for her I'm not a stripper
I'm a recording artist and an actress
and I've not broken any laws I had
nothing to do it is recording
she can't read a whole sentence at one
time no well that's what is pretty
surety Jake like she has to stick to
that stick it's not like she can't like
hello my name is like you can't read a
whole sentence she might be nervous her
spit sound like she had dry mouth should
be the worst person to do public reading
this user you know popcorn reading in
school and there's always that one
[ __ ] that retail is slow that would be
her pay all right it's hard okay [ __ ]
jail and lure somebody [ __ ] shoot me
in the face
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]
[Music]